if only they could look behind the
curtain and see the consistency see the
hard work see the sweat see the Jack the
jacked up hands you know like the hours
that I put in the 16 17 18 hours a day
you're like you want to know why my
businesses are successful it's because I
put everything into it like that hard
work with consistency over time and
equal success it's heartbreaking when I
see somebody that wants to be something
and I know they'll never do what it
takes to be that as you're getting ready
for a fight high on the emotion I'm
getting ready to go overseas on a
deployment you know I I have a ton of
adrenaline you know I have a little bit
of fear I have to be showing up I have
to be technically working on a skill I
have to be trying to find how to get to
that next level I'm seeking out
professionals I would go all over the
world to find these people to train with
me they would beat me I didn't like that
you're not going to get better in an
environment that you're the best